there it is
that is cool bar
properties
you so i've just arrived at an estate
agency and it's actually this is owned
by one of my students raheem barr
i can't wait to meet him i'm catching up
with some of his staff right now who's
saying that he's a really
good person to work with is that right
yes he's a fantastic guy to work with
he's an amazing person um yeah if i
could give you a little bit of my
background on how i met him
um literally four weeks ago
i was in my car living in my car you're
living in your car
exactly i was kicked out you know of my
house and after 18 years of marriage
uh because of kobe mesa said oh you're
useless now you know i don't
because i work as a self-employed all
the time and uh
so anyway we're you know been building
about the crash car you came to the
crossroads and said
leave the house and you know we don't
need you anymore so okay
right pick a few things and head out and
the
place i wanted to come to was a seaside
so anyway i ended up in swansea
and didn't like swansea after a week
came down to caddy
and i was in my car and i used to go
around for an
hour work so one day i walked past here
and i saw this gentleman talking to
somebody and i thought it's probably the
you know business owner i never know him
i don't know him from anywhere
so i went away came back and another day
and i
came in and said right i'm larry you
know have a chat with him generally
i thought group you know on whatsapp
you know uh property uh investors you
know i'm trying to
you know coach to buy properties and
we'll sell you know
so i told him about i said right you
know what you've come to the right place
and i told him about my situation and i
said all right you know what
i'm going to get mrs to make you dinner
every night
and uh you can come and walk with me
i'll show you what i know so it's a so
it was a ton around that wow that's
incredible dude
and today you know i've been closing
deals and doing stuff
so yeah the guy is amazing since then
you know i've been walking with him and
stitching me you know uh everything and
i've been on the courses you know we've
got some students online out you know
he teaches on saturday we've got another
course coming on this saturday
so i will be on there as well good yeah
so so well you know the good thing about
is that you know already have
a fired up person yeah you know already
have some
background knowledge and uh properties
and whatnot
and then to have landed on his lab and
he
gave you know open his door to me it's
just amazing
how's it going man
i have to go back to let one of the
cleaners she came around and she forgot
the
well she doesn't got a bicycle so i have
to drop out of this dude
i'm really glad to see you being well
done man it's so good i mean thanks
buddy you know
it's all with your energy and your
motivation and the
hints and tips you
and also um great to see you got some
great people brand new as well
yeah she said do you come here like
every day
i'm here almost every day yeah not
almost up here everyday
yeah right this is like because i don't
see my business as a business i see it
as a hobby
yeah so obviously i come in sometimes i
mean from eight seven sometimes
to like eight in the evening you know
because that's yeah as a hobby so
stay here do some deals much time on a
hobby but yeah right
i don't i love you i love it i love it i
love it
i don't wanna ever have like private
conversations stuff like that we take it
at the back
and that is fun thank you very much
thank you very much just so thank you
for the visit basically because you've
taken your time you've been here and
you don't have to come around there so
no it's a real pleasure thank you very
much
our property market was doing really
well actually um before kobe
yeah and for the last two decades
property prices goes up by 240 percent
wow
it was about 255
yeah grandstand was this area was one of
the
lowest capital appreciation area for the
last few years it has been the best
property prices went from say hundred
thousand to
two hundred thousand this area within
the last two years
right the only impact they have now is
because obviously coffee planting
kicks in all the property sales were
caused
and now it has picked up now now if
you've got a property here it doesn't
take
a week to go
[Music]
20 years ago they actually destroyed all
the sort of factories they had there
and built this apartment so they built
this apartment all the way at the end of
this road
and hoping to get um celebrities to to
buy them
but then 2008 we re recession hits
and then the prices went down and people
picked them up for next to nothing
and now they're worth about two bedroom
house
two-bedroom apartment worth about 160
thousand pounds
and they bought it really really cheap
then look at this
massive i've made so many inquiries on
this
you know do you know who owns it i know
i found out on
land registry i know who owns it he's
written them letters few times
so obviously i'm doing that for now
we've got the same eye now exactly
the one building our spot this is the
one i'm also chasing this one if we can
get a luxury apartment here
we're absolutely killing it right and
uh yeah very nice sort of area
to have essays yeah and obviously to
target what are the rules about service
accommodation in in cardiff or wales
well there's no specific rule at the
moment you haven't brought the rules
from the uk as far as i'm aware
to cardiff you could rent it out it's
normal let and then do whatever you want
to do with it are your rent to rent
mostly si or hmr um i have both i have
essays
and i have rent to rent right because
if stuff like this happen you could
easily let them out
right because what i did was because i
secured good deals on my essays
i was able to actually rent them out of
snow mallet
and still make profit out of them how
many students do you have
oh i've got loads yeah i've got
in terms of students i've got lots of
them but the mentee side of things
um i only want to take a maximum of 12
people
because i want to provide that one to
one so i can add value a lot
more impact than positively rather than
having one too many
our houses in this area basically okay
all our hmo properties
90 of them are in this area right we've
got one
we've got field there few on that road
few behind us and
those properties around here they rent a
rent property i must have my renter
ah okay so you've basically got lots of
rent to rents all around here yes all
around there yeah so you can go straight
and on
average yeah on average how much does
one rent to rent property making on
average about
you can do leftists about maybe five to
six hundred pounds
yeah if it's five six japan profit a
month net profit yeah
and how much does it cost to set up a
rent to rent in the first place
well it depends on the condition as what
i tend to do
i look for properties that can add value
to we
we've got two here that there
and we go into number 68
so this one here um a bit about the
background so they are working
professional so obviously i said i see
no
we don't mix our tenants um you have to
be working
or doing a master's program for you to
be able to live in our houses so i don't
do lhas
or stuff like that so instead of getting
this student now what i do is to get
masters or phd students that would look
after the property yeah
and that way they also stay longer
because most of the phd and master's
student they've got 18 month program so
once they're in
they're there for 18 months yeah so you
can easily just rent and forget
right whereas if you've got student
they're only there for about six seven
months of the year
and then come now for example um july
august the property will be vacant
because there's no uni they will go back
home
yeah so one of my secrets also
that is the time i tend to get landlords
right
because that time landlord needs you
because they are worried about these two
two moms whether
they the agent would be able to fill
their house up yeah okay
yeah right so if you're going listen i
can take this property on you so what
kind of month is that or what's it so
it's now basically yeah july
august september is the buying point
because they know especially the
property's not been led by september
they know
union will start in september so they
need to get it going
i used to spend lots of money in the
common areas yeah but what i've learned
was people don't use it
yeah as you can see here brand new tv
look at that
i bought this about three years ago
right but look
still still they haven't been touched
this is a seven bedroom house
like that right and then average on this
one is about
um 650 if all rooms are left
it's net yeah so 650 is what you make
profit net yes yeah and how full is this
generally
it's is normally always for yeah and the
only difficulties we had was during
kovid some people were struggling some
people lost their jobs
but this the last one is gone today you
saw yesterday yeah so
um this one is fully let now and yeah so
it's gonna kick from that so what i did
was also during cohere
is to go back to the landlord so tell
them listen this is the situation
i cannot i may not i use that word for
me i may not be able to give a
guaranteed rent anymore
however whatever rent i collect i'll
take my
expenses out and give you the balance
sure until we get through the recession
or until you get through call with 19.
you think that with hmos it's actually
an advantage
to have a very low maintenance garden of
course
always an advantage if not then you'd
have to get your gardeners around
because if most people if you're buying
a house to live in
you might think oh this garden's not
very good but
for hmo it's better because the tenants
i bet they don't spend time out here no
they don't come out here so unless
they're going to smoke right
so it's low maintenance which means no
money yes and the tenants are really
happy yeah absolutely
we're handed these back to the landlords
why are you handing it back
because the landlord is looking to sell
i did not do a good negotiation like
this
oh okay this was before the deal finding
extravaganza
yeah so basically i don't do it could do
a good negotiation
yeah i was subsidizing it with other
properties that landlord referred me to
yeah right so obviously because he
referred me to about
five over deals i might as well take
that now yeah keep it
until when i cannot do it so you've got
you've got eight properties from this
landlord here
oh well let's travel the seven around
this probably got four toilets basically
i think it's important to hand it back
in good quality because you'll maintain
the relationship
yeah you definitely have to do that you
want to go the extra mile
that's it some people just handed back
the ladies but i don't do that
i want you to get your property back if
not better but
it's the same way i took it back from
here
next door as well so you've got two
extra bedrooms it's really interesting
because loft conversions
can add a lot of value to the house if
done right and this is how it should be
done
absolutely two bedrooms probably cost
him 25 grand
well that's because he's a he's a
builder himself all right less than that
and they'll probably have increased the
value by 50 60 grand
because this property is going to be on
the mark i'm selling this way many ways
right
so um he's looking at about i think 350
is looking for
yeah 250k for it i'm trying to negotiate
with him see if i can get it
um the actual value for this would be
about 370.
yeah we wanted to take 350. so this
property
you secured this a few years back didn't
you yeah
just after the crash course yeah
how how soon after the property
investors did did you get this deal well
maybe a couple of days later because
when i came back i was just literally
i wasn't sleeping i was looking for
deals but that was before you did any
advanced training yes so you had another
deal finding extravaganza or anything
then
um and then when you did the advanced
training you thought hmm it wasn't the
best deal in the world after all
why have you kept it for so many years
if this deal wasn't really that great
um because one i've signed the contract
and i don't want to deceive the landlord
i've agreed to for me my
my my words are my bond yeah if i said
yes to you
it's gonna be yes and obviously i was
able to also convince him to say
that if he could refer me to other
landlords
i may be able to keep the property
because i can use the profit i make from
those to actually subsidize this one
because this was actually making a loss
yeah this one
wasn't making a loss if one room is
empty i'm making a loss
right if all the rooms are rented i'm
break even so basically it was a really
bad rental really
bad deal yeah everything is bad in it
basically but the
but the funny thing about it is you know
i think he used the kitchen is the
one that knocks me over when i saw the
kitchen was really nice and
really appealing yeah and then i just
said you know what i can accept that
deal so was it almost
feelings not formulas exactly yeah the
deal that's not a great deal
is still better than no deal yeah
because you got the relationship there i
go
look for properties i can add value to
yeah the reason why
it's a win-win in most cases those
landlords are struggling
anyways so you could come in and
structure a nice sort of deal
with them and ask them for a rent-free
period yeah
right so you've got the property of them
you're doing the works for them
and you're going to be guaranteeing
their rent once you take the property on
yeah right so that way i've added value
not just on the landlord's point of view
as well as on the property yeah so that
then allows me to get
properties at discount yeah rather than
waiting until the landlord does
everything
so welcome in so what for example you
might if you needed to do a little
refurb and spend a few thousand you
might just say look i'll do the refurb
but then i want to rent
rent free for six months plus there's a
catch yeah anyway
we can share the roof of cost right 50
50. okay
right if you're happy we do it and you
don't have to pay the money what i will
do i will deduct it from the rent i pay
you
okay what would you say to someone that
said rent to rent
yeah it's too good to be true or it's
not realistic
well this is an example we're in a
rental and property right so
um it's doable it's hard work but with
the right coach and mentor
you can absolutely do it yeah you know
and it's just about you going out there
getting used to knows
because lots of people don't know about
renter but now people starting to learn
about it know about it now but when we
started
if you tell someone rent to rent they
don't even understand what you're
talking about sorry
this side is all like the richest area
in cardiff
that's bellamy's house
average house here is about
one million or so oh this happened is
this the one you're doing a direct round
yeah this is the one that we are we've
just taken we're doing some work this is
a little bit different to the other
houses
this one i'm targeting a different
market right let me guess
let me guess so there's obviously
student
professional boutique this is going to
be the top yeah that's the top one
yeah what's the right area for us this
is already been reserved by the way
this is gone tenants is moving on friday
okay i need to get everything done
before friday basically how much are
they going to be playing
they'll be paying about 580.
okay so quite high yeah but considering
there's not an ensuite
no how many bathrooms two okay two
bathrooms to five people so that's okay
and we are targeting professionals as
well they're very busy people so they're
going to stay in here constantly
how much are you paying the landlord
each month oh you don't want to know
it's about one thousand
it's about one thousand three fifty
that's not much
that is not much but if you've got five
how much they're going for here five
bedrooms
how much is going for two thousand
pounds it's definitely high end
and they just normally just decent
decent-sized room but
it's a lot of money and you've got
people secured
no yeah definitely this one is secured
those those two we're doing viewings the
other one's already secured as well so
what kind of what kind of people live
here in this area
or in these rooms your town in this room
they're all working for probably talking
about managers
um people that work for bank or law
firms
that are here maybe just for the week
they're going back to their families
how do you find this how did you find
this landlord
how did they find out let me think um
i approached them and this one was on
leaflet drops
actually so wrote them a letter similar
to what you told us to do
post it to the property and then they
picked it up and then they
they rang me and then the result went
and viewed the properties
you gotta that's the thing though like
it's so simple
you just send them a letter but did you
did you leaflet drop this whole area
i'm not i i target it new sorry lift
drop this old area but then the
landlords
i target them how did you know that this
landlord existed well one
is walking to the house a school donates
because i like this area i've lived in
this area before
yeah so just walked in and spoke to one
of the
tenants downstairs when her in-law lives
downstairs asked who the owner was and
who she was yeah i liked her and she
lived just down the road
yeah right right now she was happy met
her with our partner don't deal straight
away so did the landlords
when you sent the letter did the
landlord get in touch and
how did you manage that negotiation yes
they got in touch
asked me if i'm still interested i said
yes i'm interested and then obviously
create the booking
and the viewings i create urgency say
okay i'm very busy i've got so many
deals coming if you want this deal to be
part of those deals
we need to reinterview as soon as
possible but this property
1 350 pound is what you're paying yeah
you're renting out
five rooms for about 520 to up to 580
each
but you're only paying half of the rent
to the landlord
until the end of the year and the rent
to the landlord includes
the bills on the house so you're going
to be making a nice clean monthly profit
on this
and you found it just by sending a
letter sending that
out yeah that's it you know and to be
honest with you um
when when i started it was diff it was
hard for me obviously because you have
to actually sell yourself a lot more
but once you know what you're doing
you're used to it
no deal is big for you you can just just
a normal deal
you can go and be with confidence you
know okay i don't get it
so this this landlord then what's his
situation because you mentioned you were
thinking about going down a
loa route yes i'm thinking probably um
to be able to do a rent to buy
on your property so that um i'll be able
to buy it in the future because i may
see this as a home basically because
would you live here yeah i want to i
want i would like to convert it
into something like the property
at the back of the house yeah convert it
into sort of a nice sort of
property um in the long run so once
we've agreed on to purchase this option
i'll start applying for i'm planning
straight
do you think you'll say yes i think
she'll say yes because i've already told
that build a good relationship with her
and she likes me personally
so so so this property is making you as
a rent to rent
yeah it's making you over a thousand
pounds a month yeah but you're wanting
to secure a purchase price down the line
how many years
uh maybe five years five years and then
you're going to use that profit profit
i've already made
to actually do the property off i'm
really impressed with raheem's property
deals
i think that it seems like cardiff is
such a gold mine of an area
but i think it's what you make of it the
thing is with raheem is is he's
an intelligent hard worker that knows
knows his topic he's a grafter
and he's just made this his gold mine
patch but i believe you can do that
pretty much anywhere as long as you're
the right person
uh it's not about having a magical area
or having a big secret it's just about
getting the right knowledge implementing
it in
an area and turn it into your gold mine
area so really impressed
thank you thank you so much for watching
i hope you enjoyed that
we're now back at the office i'm gonna
have a cup of coffee with raheem
guys if you enjoyed the video please do
smash the like button don't forget to
subscribe you can subscribe right here
if you want to see rahim's first
interview where i chat to him about his
story
you can check that out right here and i
look forward to seeing you next time